[musique]
Henry Proglioto. Bonsoir.
Bonsoir.
Nous vous recevons pour une chaîne
internet qui s'appelle Syer Review. Nous
sommes en direct. Est-ce que vous pouvez
vous présenter succintement ?
Euh oui, [raclement de gorge] bien sûr.
Euh
je suis né bien longtemps en Tibal
Maritime.
Euh j'ai fait euh
mes études primaires et secondaires en
Tib et euh prépa à Nice
en même temps que mon frère jumeau. Ça
c'est nous intégrons tous les deux HEC
en 1971
et après mon service militaire euh
j'intègre
enfin je finis en 71 donc je et
j'intègre la générale des eau après mon
service militaire en 1972 par petites
annonces comme attaché stagiaire à la
compagnie des eaux
et je pensais y rester 3 ans. J'y ai
passé 39 ans de ma vie.
Euh, j'ai fait à peu près tous les
métiers. Je j'ai reconnu
à Guid de Joanny qui a été mon grand
président pendant si longtemps. Une
qualité énorme, c'est que ça a été un
grand bâtisseur d'empire. Il nous
laissait immense liberté. Enfin, on y on
ira peut-être un peu plus tard dans la
dans nos discussions, mais je
[grognement] lui dois beaucoup et il m'a
indirectement puis directement beaucoup
appris
et déformé puisque son concept de
l'entreprise c'était pas plus pas de
réunion de plus de personnes,
pas de communication,
pas de pas de note de service
et surtout pas d'organigramme.
L'entreprise, elle doit être biologique
ou elle n'est pas. Donc tout ça m'a
beaucoup déformé et formé.
J'ai donc passé un très long très longue
période
gravi tous les échelons pour arriver à
la présidence
pendant une dizaine d'années avant de
rejoindre DF comme patron de DF en fin
d'année 2009.
Et j'ai fini mon mandat en fin 2014
début 2015 et depuis
j'ai créé ma propre petite structure.
Voilà mon parcours.
[grognement]
On vous on a décidé de vous faire venir
ce soir pour parler énergie, guerre
économique, Europe, Allemagne, euh
perspective nucléaire et tout un tas de
choses comme ça.
On a mis comme titre [gémissement]
un truc qui ressemble à est-ce que
l'Europe nous a délibérément
fait mal à EDF ou l'Allemagne ?
Qu'est-ce que vous pensez de ça ? Quand
j'écoute l'audition concernant la
souveraineté économique, j'ai
l'impression que certains laissent
paraître entre les lignes qu'on a subi
une une opération de guerre économique
allemande de basse intensité pour saper
un des piliers de la France EDF.
Est-ce que c'est
ça peut se reconnaître comme ça ? Est-ce
que c'est le hasard ? Est-ce que c'est
est-ce que ce n'est ça n'est pas du tout
? D'ailleurs,
pour parler franchement, est-ce que les
Allemands nous l'ont fait à l'envers ?
Les Allemands ont défendu des intérêts
de l'Allemagne
qu'on peut pas le reprocher.
Euh j'ai eu à répondre à cette question
à peu près dans les mêmes termes euh
qui m'était posé par la commission
d'enquête parlementaire. Comme vous le
savez, je je m'exprime rarement et j'ai
refusé toute interview depuis les débuts
de la crise énergétique.
Là, j'étais obligé de comparaître devant
la commission et la question m'a été
posée à peu près de la même manière,
c'est-à-dire au fond comment est en
est-on arrivé à cette situation, comment
est-ce que la France a perdu son
indépendance énergétique et euh
et qui en sont les responsables ?
Je me suis permis de rappeler en
quelques mots ce qui était à
mes yeux, ce qu'avait été le formidable
l'aventure française en matière
d'énergie
qui depuis 46 a marqué non seulement les
esprits mais en même temps
ce pays de ses conséquences.
Alors 1946, la France est dans un état
comme vous le savez difficile et le
gouvernement de l'époque gauliste
communiste,
projette une vision de ce pays à long
terme et considère que parmi les
éléments structurels, les éléments
essentiels dont il faut savoir tenir
compte, l'énergie en fait partie est une
variable stratégique.
constate que la France
est dans une situation délicate, n'ayant
que très peu de ressources
sur son territoire, pas de gaz, pas de
pétrole, peu de charbon par rapport à
ses voisins.
Que d'autre part, nous importons
l'essentiel de notre énergie et
notamment de l'électricité aussi et
qu'il est essentiel
de relever trois défis. le défi de
l'indépendance énergétique du pays, le
défi de sa compétitivité,
un troisème défi imposé par les
communistes à l'époque
qui est le service public de
l'électricité, c'est-à-dire au fond une
conception
très originale qui consiste à vouloir
accorder à tous les Français, quel que
soit leur class sociale, quel que soit
leur lieu de résidence sur le
territoire, l'accès à l'énergie au même
prix avec la même qualité de service.
Ça s'appelle le service public, le
service public de l'énergie, de
l'électricité. En tout cas,
50 ans plus tard, à la fin au début du
21e siècle, les trois défis ont été
remportés. Nous sommes indépendants en
terme d'électricité et exportateur
d'énergie électrique. Nous avons le prix
le moins cher d'Europe,
de fois à de fois et demi moins cher que
l'Allemagne et notre contrat de service
public fait référence dans le monde
entier.
Nous avons remporté un 4è défi auquel
nous n'étions pas confrontés à l'époque,
c'est que du fait des choix
technologiques qui ont été opéré,
le nucléaire et l'hydraulique, nous
sommes le pays qui met le moins de CO2
dans la fabrication de son énergie.
C'est-à-dire au fond, c'est un défi qui
serait aujourd'hui considéré comme
fondamental ou prioritaire qui à
l'époque n'existait pas et que nous
avons remporté sans le vouloir vraiment.
Alors, comment ça tout ceci s'est fait ?
C'est fait par d'abord une vision,
deuxièmement
un choix technologique,
je le disais à l'instant, l'hydraulique
et le nucléaire
qui n'étaiit pas des choix faciles.
L'hydraulique imposait des
investissements très lourds sur des
durées très longues.
Le nucléaire imposait des choix
technologiques encore plus sophistiqués.
D'ailleurs, ils n'ont pas été immédiat
puisqu'on a varié au cours des années.
On on a changé notre notre fusil
d'épaule mais sans jamais changer de
cap.
On a fini par l'eau pressurisée et la
grande aventure que vous connaissez
et
dire au service de de cette ambition une
organisation c'està-dire
le CEA pour la recherche fondamentale et
et les orientations
de technologie.
un opérateur
en même temps
chef de fil
et et architecte ensemblier de
l'ensemble EDF
et puis un outil industriel framesom
d'un côté Cogéma de l'autre l'un pour la
partie d'industrie lourde l'autre pour
la partie
de retraitement et et et
je dirais de traitement des déchets et
et combustible.
Et puis cette équipe de France s'est
entourée évidemment de toute une série
d'entreprises qui constitue la filière
industrielle autour de
je dirais l'ambition nucléaire et
également hydraulique d'ailleurs dans un
dans un autre sens
avec un concept qui est
un outil intégré incluant à la fois la
production, la distribution, le
transport, l'optimisation
d'un système électrique qui s'est voulu
optimiser à tous les niveaux
et qui a été réalisé autour de
l'opérateur service public,
opérateur et industriel, enfin en tout
cas architecte ensemblier comme je le
disais à l'instant qui s'appelait EDF
qui a été conçu pour cela à partir de la
nationalisation de 46 de tous les
opérateurs électriques français.
Donc formidable réussite. EDF
au début de ce 21e siècle dans les
années que nous avons tous connu,
c'est la référence mondiale. C'est le
premier électricien mondial en dehors
des Chinois qui sont plus difficiles à
comparer. C'est
la plus belle entreprise
dans son domaine d'activité et c'est
encore une fois un atout fondamental
pour la France.
Très bien.
Dans le même temps, les autres pays
ayant fait des choix alternatifs
différents. La Grande-Bretagne ayant
fait du nucléaire, l'Allemagne aussi un
peu. S'est en lancé elle-même dans
l'aventure nucléaire avec Simens.
Est-ce qu'on peut Je vous coupe, est-ce
qu'on peut dire ça ? Est-ce qu'on peut
qualifier ça d'une stratégie non
coopérative
que ce soit les anglais ou les Allemands
?
Non. Euh
[raclement de gorge]
l'énergie fait partie des domaines
stratégiques pour chaque pays. Chaque
pays a sa vision
de ce sujet.
Alors, l'Europe s'est constituée
entre-temps puisqueentre 1946 et
aujourd'hui, entre-temps, on a constitué
l'Union européenne, enfin comité
du charbon et de l'acier puis l'Union
européenne,
mais forcé de constater que cette Union
européenne s'est constituée sans mettre
en commun ni la pol ni l'énergie, ni la
politique énergétique, ni même la
politique économique,
ni la politique fiscale, ni la politique
de défense. On a cette originalité
d'avoir créé une union
sans autre relation, je dirais
qui ne qui au fond s'est installé
progressivement,
qui a énoncé un certain nombre de règles
de comportement ou de règles de vie
qui a créé une monnaie commune pour la
un certain nombre de ces pays he puisque
aujourd'hui l'euro la zone euro concerne
partie importante mais pas la totalité
des pays de l'Europe de l'Union
européenne mais c'est une monnaie qui
n'est adossée à aucune politique
fiscale, économique ou industriel
commune. C'est très étrange.
C'est la seule monnaie que je connaisse
qui tient
par l'opération du Saint-Esprit,
non par une par une volonté politique,
mais par une cohérence
des
des Étatsmembres
en matière d'économiste, d'économie
libérale avec un certain nombre de
règles communes, mais on est loin de
l'intégration des pays d'Europe. Donc au
fond, l'énergie ne fait pas exception.
énergie c'était alors on a créé des
interconnexions, on a créé des relations
entre les pays de Bandia qui puisse y
avoir un commerce et non pas une union
mais une coordination entre les divers
pays européens mais pas euh pas plus au
fond. Donc la France avait un modèle
original, l'Allemagne avait un autre
modèle qui était irrité de son passé, de
sa structure d'ailleurs fédérale parce
que
il en est même de l'Italie d'ailleurs
euh qui a qui a des opérateurs
nationaux et des opérateurs plus
régionaux. Donc la France a fait ce
choix-là et ce choix s'est avéré
pertinent pour notre pays. En tout cas,
est-ce que l'Europe, l'Allemagne, on
cherche à nous faire des petits crochept
? Est-ce que pour l'Allemagne se
retrouver avec la France et une
production énergétique 40 % moins cher
que ses copains et c'était un danger
pour l'Allemagne ? Est-ce que vous
pensez que ils ont jugé ça comme un
danger et ont mené une opération de
basse intensité sur des années pour nous
saper le le nucléaire ?
D'abord, au départ, l'Allemagne a voulu
aussi se lancer dans le nucléaire, s'est
lancé dans le nucléaire et puis au fond
avec moins d'ambition et donc moins de
réussite que la France. Et puis
tout s'est compliqué au moment du
lancement de la politique allemande de
ce qu'ils appellent l'energ,
c'est-à-dire le
le virage énergétique, ce qu'on peut
appeler aujourd'hui
une politique de transition, on appelle
transition enfin énergétique qui a été
un échec
phénoménal pour l'Allemagne.
avec comme conséquence
euh des dépenses
considérables dans le renouvelable
puisque l'Allemagne a investi à ce jour
plus de 500 milliards d'euros dans le
renouvelable. Bon, l'Europe dans son
ensemble à peu près 1000 milliards,
l'Allemagne s'instant à elle toute
seule.
Euh
pour des raisons circonstantielles euh
lors de Fukushima, l'Allemagne s'est
décidé de sortir du nucléaire. Raison
que j'ai expliqué d'ailleurs à la à
l'Assemblée nationale.
Euh en tout cas, c'est un des grands
échecs de la politique allemande des 20
dernières années.
Les Allemands sont parfaitement lucides,
ils le savent. Les deux grands
électriciens allemands sont dans une
situation épouvantable alors qu'ils
étaient des
majeurs de l'industrie dans les
tout au long de la deuxème moitié du du
20e siècle.
Euh et
bon, l'Allemagne consciente de sa
faiblesse
avait une raison supplémentaire de son
inquiété, c'est que
son option principale, son choix, ça a
été de se construire comme une
un pays industriel
et depuis Willy Brand,
la vocation industrielle d'une part et
l'ost politique de l'autre
ont été l'action principale de la
stratégie allemande
qui leur a permis d'ailleurs
une assez brillante réussite
industrielle.
Euh nul ne peut l'ignorer avec juste
mais avec cet échec dans le domaine de
l'énergie qui est marqué d'autant plus
que c'était
un élément de
d'affaiblissement de sa stratégie
industrielle.
Euh l'Allemagne, considérant que son
échec dans ce domaine était d'autant
plus flagrant et d'autant plus
douloureux qu'à sa porte, la France
disposait d'un outil euh formidablement
efficace
et que par conséquence cet atout
compétitif
l'a gêné. Bon, il est totalement évident
que l'intérêt d'Allemagne n'était pas
que DF maintiennent
cette cette originalité, cette force et
que les Allemands n'ont eu de cesse à
travers la règle européenne en
respectant parfaitement
l'organisation telle qu'elle existe
aujourd'hui. C'estàd f utilis comme un
outil pour imposer des règles qui
allaient euh
obligéf
à une
désintégration. Appelons un chat un
chat. C'est-à-dire au fond, les règles
européennes ont d'abord interdit à EDF
la propriété des réseaux, c'est-à-dire
que les réseaux étaient en commun
carrière et et que tous les producteurs
devaient avoir un accès identique à leur
à leur réseau et par conséquent, il
fallait absolument éviter que DF
continue
à avoir le contrôle de son réseau de
transport et progressivement le contrôle
de son réseau de distribution.
Aujourd'hui,
EDF a cette originalité
qu'elle n'a plus le droit d'accéder à
ses clients. Ça c'était la première
chose.
La deuxième règle conceptuellement,
c'était de dire
l'Europe s'est construite sur une
théorie, sur une vision qui est le
bonheur des peuples et directement
corrélé avec la concurrence. Et donc
pour que les peuples soient heureux, il
faut qu'il puissent avoir une
concurrence claire dans chacun des
secteurs d'activité.
cet objet quif
par son monopole dérogé à cette
norme ou à cette
cette doctrine et par conséquent il
fallait absolument imposer à EDF des
concurrents.
Et alors plutôt que de favoriser
des aventures industrielles concurrentes
qui était possible encore que on en
avait pas besoin et bien il a été décidé
d'imposer à EDF
de créer des concurrents virtuels,
c'està-dire de vendre son énergie à des
concurrents qui pouvaient ensuite la
revendre au client de DF, sachant que
cette énergie devait être vendue à ses
concurrents en dessous de son prix de
revient.
Comme ça au moins il pouvait vivre.
Ce qui a donné la loi nomme nouvelle
organisation du marché de l'électricité
ce qui a donné naissance à au coup de
session la reine
qui c'est qui a fait passer la loi la
loi ?
une série de ministres mais en tout cas
c'est c'est ça répondait à une attente
de Bruxelles. Clairement, je me suis
mobilisé
avec toute l'énergie dont je suis
capable contre ces aberrations avec le
succès, vous constatez, c'est-à-dire
euh
sans blasé,
non, déçu.
Déçu parce qu'on
on en connaissait les conséquences.
Bon, je sais pas si c'est mieux ou pire.
Enfin, en tout cas, les conséquences
pour expliquer à notre communauté, ça va
être quoi les conséquences quand on a un
EDF qui se fait euh les conséquences,
c'est facile quand
vous avez un outil qui est optimisé et
que vous le cassez en morceau, vous
désoptimisez l'outil, ça c'est clair.
Bon, quand par ailleurs vous vous
imposez, si EDF qui était autrefois un
opérateur global devient un simple
producteur indépendant, soumis à
concurrence qui est un autre modèle.
et que bon très bien mais quand en plus
vous la vous lui imposez de vendre 25 %
de sa production électronucléaire
assez concurrent encore une fois virtuel
à un prix très inférieur à son coût de
revient pour qu'il puisse le revendre au
prix de marché à vos propres clients, ça
devient assez sportif. Donc c'est les
menottes, le boulet et en plus la
saignée.
D'autant plus que aucun de ces
concurrents n'a aucune obligation de
production.
Donc on a créé une vraie richesse, un
patrimoine formidable financier à des
gens qui sont des traders
et qui en plus financent des campagnes
de publicité fantastique. Puisque je le
citais là aussi.
Moi ça m'a amusé. Le terme est un peu
excessif quand je regarde la télé de
voir
les gens prétendent vendre de l'énergie
verte alors qu'ils achetaient les
l'électricité de DF pour la revendre au
clients de DF en prenant une marge
conséquente entre les deux et qu'elle
était réputée verte.
C'était la même puisqu'il ne fabrique
rien. Bon,
autrefois, il existait un bureau de
de vérification de la publicité, vous
savez, qui sanctionnait les publicités
mensongères. J'ai jamais compris
pourquoi on avait pas activé ce ce
système là disant "Mais attendez,
qu'est-ce que ça a de verre ? Enfin,
c'est mon électricité électronucléaire
qui est verte." Bon, moi j'admirais
beaucoup les Suisses parce que les
Suisses ont toujours été des gens
formidables. On leur vendait de
l'électricité nucléaire, il revendaiit
de l'électricité verte aux Italiens
parce que ils prétendaient que c'était
celle de leur barrage. Bon euh après
tout
le blanchiment, on sait que c'est une
grande spécialité des Suisses. Donc
Oui. Et puis et puis bien d'autres
choses. Enfin, c'est des gens for
c'est des gens formidables et bon mais
ça c'est un clin d'œil amusé parce que
j'aime beaucoup les Suisses
mais là on l'a fait en France. C'est
bon tact. Euh
alors euh euh la conséquence, vous
posiez la question de la conséquence,
c'est que bah tout ça a créé une
explosion des coûts
malgré les pertes considérables qu'on a
qui qui en ont été le résultat DF, ben
le client, il a vu sa facture s'alourdir
d'une manière conséquente.
Ça va continuer.
Oui, enfin il y a pas de raison
fondamentale pour que ça s'arrête. Euh
si je vous rajoute si je vous rajoute
là-dessus Hercule, ça vous parle ? C'est
quoi Hercule ?
Oh, c'était une étape supplémentaire de
désintégration de DF.
Organisé par qui et quand ? [soupir]
Ça ça n'a pas été organisé, ça a été
évoqué comme une idée.
[grognement]
Mais dès lors qu'on assiste au
démembrement
parce qu'il faut pas aller un peu plus
loin, moi quand j'ai rejoint EDF en fin
d'année 2009, la grande préoccupation de
mes cadres c'était
l'obligation faite à l'entreprise de
lancer des appels d'offre de mise en
concurrence de ces barrages
parce que les barrages sont la propriété
de l'État. Enfin, ça c'est
de nous
donc oui de du des Français. Euh mais
EDF était l'opérateur unique.
Euh [gémissement]
alors un barrage ça sert à quoi ? Ça
sert à fabriquer de du mais ça sert
surtout à stocker. C'està dire que c'est
un élément d'optimisation du système. On
utilise les barrages tout
particulièrement quand on fait la
maintenance des centrales ou ou ou pour
gérer les pointes et cetera. Donc un
barrage isolé par définition désoptimisé
puisque
si vous le mettez un appel d'offre,
personne ne va payer cet objet, cet
actif plus cher que sa capacité de
production. La capacité de stockage
immatérielle, elle implique qu'elle soit
intégrée dans un ensemble. Et donc ça
revenait à pauvrir la France, à pauvrir
EDF sans aucune autre contrepartie. Euh
mais c'est la conséquence et la je
dirais naturelle des
décision Bruxelloise
et c'est inscrit dans la règle et dans
la loi. Ça l'est toujours
ça a été confirmé là. Ouis.
Bon, moi j'avais eu parti du principe
assez maladroit certes mais réaliste.
Bon cassel tienne je ne le ferai pas et
on payera des amendes. Il était
préférable pour la France de payer des
amendes plutôt que d'accepter c
démembrement et cette désoptimisation
supplémentaire.
Bon et et bon voilà une série de
conséquences directes ou indirectes
de cette démarche.
Alors après, on peut toujours dire
il va y avoir une entreprise nationale
pour le nucléaire, il va y avoir une
mise en concurrence et donc des
entreprises diverses pour les barrages,
il y aura une entreprise pour le réseau
de distribution, une entreprise pour le
réseau de transport. Euh
c'est comme ça qu'on sucre les fraises.
Chacun son tour.
Non mais c'est comme ça qu'on détruit un
outil. Voilà. Alors
quand vous êtes parti dans de DF, la
boîte était en bonne santé, les gens
étaient relativement contents là
malgré malgré cela, malgré la reine,
malgré la reine en plus.
Oubliez pas.
Ah ouais sinon ça aurait été de deux
fois meilleur.
Je n'ai pas échappé
au pillage lié au
pillage c'est le mot.
Oui.
Alors, on va parler français comme au
village. Vous êtes patron, vous laissez
la boîte correcte, on vous met des sensu
qui vous vampirise à gauche et à droite.
Là, vous voyez l'histoire vous est
absou, le nucléaire est nécessaire pour
la France. Quand vous voyez la politique
énergétique française qui n'est pas une
politique énergétique mais qui est unat
de de dialogue politique pour faire de
la subordination de vote, vous avez pas
envie de tout casser et dire "Mais non,
ça suffit les conneries.
L'énergie pour la France, c'est notre
sang, c'est notre façon de résister à la
mondialisation, d'être là et pour
pouvoir imposer nos valeurs. Si on avait
pas l'électricité, c'était compliqué.
Vous avez pas envie de de ruer dans les
brancards. Je vous sens vachement
pondéré, vachement calme mais comme une
colère froide et sourde.
Je n'ai jamais été un grand calme mais
mais
au fond
j'ai essayé de respecter les valeurs qui
m'ont été enseignées. C'estàdire au fond
1 le dévouement et le patriotisme
de
l'effort et le travail
et toi le respect des institutions. J'ai
alerté euh
qui quand ? Comment ? Combien de fois ?
Souvent. Euh mes interlocuteurs souvent
qui étaient
les divers ministres ? J'en ai eu
beaucoup. Euh les responsables au-dessus
des ministres et les responsables
au-dessus de ceux qui étaient audessus
des ministres.
J'ai alerté euh les représentants euh
puisque j'ai été interrogé plusieurs
fois par la représentation nationale.
Bon, dans le cadre tout à fait naturel
de
euh soit de
de commission d'enquête, soit simplement
d'interrogation qui m'était euh
formulé par les par les élus qui sont
après tout des gens respectables et et
dans c'est la mission.
Donc j'ai j'ai alerté j'ai alerté sur la
ferm de FSM, j'ai alerté sur un certain
nombre de sujets.
J'ai parfois refusé
lorsque je considérais que mon devoir
était de ne pas accepter
et que j'en avais la possibilité, j'ai
refusé la fermeture de Fan.
Je l'ai dit à à l'Assemblée nationale,
les deux seules personnes susceptibles
ou ayant le droit de fermer une
installation
appartenant à une entreprise
de plein d'exercice comme DF, c'est le
président de DF et évidemment l'autorité
de sûreté.
Euh
c'est un exemple. Euh j'ai défendu ce
que je pensais être euh
les intérêts de l'entreprise dont
j'avais la responsabilité
et dont j'avais hérité qui était en fait
un formidable
opérateur de service public. Une arme de
guerre économique.
Oui, enfin une arme en tout cas
essentielle pour la vie du pays.
Peut-être de guerre ou de paix puisqueau
fond c'est c'est une arme essentielle
pour l'industrie et pour les foyers
français.
Il était donc naturel
d'abord
d'être fier d'un être le responsable et
par ailleurs de défendre ce que je
pensais être l'intérêt supérieur de la
nation à travers cette entreprise.
Estce que vous avez lé, est-ce que vous
avez nos différents services de sûreté
nationale en leur expliquant que cette
boîte française est un pilier que vous
on se sent attaqué,
les perspectives, la prospective de
cette attaque va nous emmener là. Est-ce
que vous avez cherché à alerter nos
services ?
Non, j'ai jamais considéré que c'était
des interlocuteurs naturels euh à cet
égard.
J'ai alerté les services sur d'autres
sujets.
Quel type ?
Les contre
les comptes informations ou les
informations perverses qui circulaient
sur tel ou tel.
Très grands collaborateurs de la maison,
les attaques
que je qualifierai de basse sur leur
loyauté. Euh je pense notamment à
l'affaire chinoise quand on le DF avait
eu
à la fois la force mais aussi l'immense
qualité
d'avoir guidé la Chine dans son aventure
nucléaire, d'avoir construit des
premières centrales nucléaires en Chine.
On avait dans ce pays une réputation
extraordinaire donc et une place de
de choix. Vous savez que tous les
responsables du nucléaire chinois
aujourd'hui parlent français parce
qu'ils ont tous été formés dans les sur
les sites de nos centrales nucléaires.
Donc c'était un atout formidable. Bon ça
a évidemment été sali et donc fut un
temps où pour laver l'honneur de la
maison, l'honneur de ses collaborateurs
les plus précieux,
j'ai alerté les services pour leur
demander de faire une enquête. Je leur
ai dit "Écoutez, la rumeur finit par
m'exaspérer. Faites votre enquête,
transmettez-en
la conclusion
àquis de droit. Si vous avez
la bienveillance suffisante, passez-moi
un coup de fil en me disant c'est fait
et comme ça je saurai que parce que je
sais le résultat et donc j'aimerais bien
que ça soit fait. Ça a été fait
propre,
nickel.
Carré cubique,
ça n'a pas empêché euh les insinuations
de continuer. Euh
on se retrouve avec euh un outil
industriel euh claudiquant comme ça que
on dit.
Non,
potentiellement euh [gémissement]
[soupir]
encore solide. Cet outil a été construit
de manière remarquable parf non sans
difficulté mais remarquable
au point que et je m'étais battu pour
cela
avant de quitter la maison. Euh j'avais
obtenu d'ailleurs satisfaction de la
dernière ministre de tutelle qui a été
euh mon interlocuteur ou locutrice.
J'avais dit "Écoutez euh il faut porter
à 60 ans la durée de vie des centrales.
Euh le aujourd'hui le système est
complètement
farfelu.
permettra au moins de gagner 20 ans et
de donner 20 ans à la fierre nucléaire
pour se réorganiser puisqu'on voyait
qu'elle était en buté à cause de pas mal
de
difficultés ou de problèmes qu'elle
avait rencontré ou qui avait été qu'on
lui avait créé et par ailleurs ça permet
même financièrement parce qu'après tout
une entreprise est quand même obligée de
faire des comptes et et donc si vous
amortissez sur une durée plus longue
Donc les les investissements de
rénovation du parc qui qu'on avait
baptisé le grand carénage. Enfin bon,
c'était pour lui donner un n en nom de
code. Et bien vous verrez que c'est
l'investissement le plus rentable que la
France peut imaginer.
Donc dès lors que les composants
principaux d'une centrale nucléaire, les
grands équipements ont des durées de vie
optimales de 30 ans, vous pouvez faire
ce qu'on pourrait appeler en matière
mécanique un échange standard de moteur
et passer 30 à 60 puisque le reste c'est
la coque, c'est le radier,
ça sa durée de vie est beaucoup peut
l'accepter sans aucune difficulté.
D'ailleurs les Américains l'avent fait
bien avant donc j'ai plaidé pour cela.
Techniquement,
c'était imparable.
Économiquement
c'était évident. Politiquement c'était
compliqué parce qu'il fallait oser dire
à certaines des tendances politiques que
vous connaissez qui sont d'une couleur
verte
que
qu'on allait pas arrêter le parc
nucléaire. Donc c'était à ce moment-là
de la vie politique française
compliquée. J'ai quand même
une réponse de principe positive
et je m'en souviendrai longtemps
de ma ministre. Et puis bon,
on parle de prospective tous les deux.
Ouais.
Vous voyez le l'état de la France,
l'État de l'Europe
d'ici 5 ans. Comment 5 10 ans ? On va
dire 5 ans parce que en tant que
prospectiviste, je doute de ceux qui
pensent à plus de 5 ans.
Alors, ce sont deux questions
différentes.
La France a beaucoup perdu de son
patrimoine industriel historique. Euh
et ce qui m'inquiète, c'est deux
chiffres qui sont inquiétants qui sont
aujourd'hui officiels. le déficit public
commerce extérieur
et le déficit du commerce extérieur qui
sont à peu près équivalent 160 milliards
chacun.
Donc quand vous avez 3500 milliards de
dettes et que vous ajoutez 320 milliards
de déficit chaque année, euh
on peut se poser des questions sur la
soutenabilité de la dette. Bon, et donc
euh sans tomber dans le pessimisme euh
il faut quand même qu'on sache réagir
pour inverser euh les tendances.
euh
le défice français là essentiellement
euh comment inverser ou réduire le
déficit public et comment inverser la
tendance qui s'est alourd manière
considérable et qui s'est aggravé. J'ai
encore en tête une interview de d'une
des nombreuses ministres du commerce
extérieur.
Vous voyez récemment, je revoyais cette
interview.
Dieu et son âme, elle s'appelait Nicole
Brick. qu'elle a été provisoirement mise
du commerce extérieur
début du quinquena de de monsieur
Hollande. Euh je voyais sur interview
parce qu'elle parlait du nucléaire du
nucléaire chinois, de la France en Chine
et cetera
et elle disait c'est dramatique, nous
avons 80 milliards de déficit de
commerce extérieur. Euh je suis là pour
redresser cette situation qui est
intenable. C'est pas si vieux.
On était à 80 milliards, elle disait
c'est intenable. Bon, on est à 160
euh
en 10 ans
2012.
Bon
les cœurs euh
on ne peut pas se dire la France
accueillira de plus en plus de touristes
étrangers et la balance
touristique améliorera les choses. Un
peu léger.
[soupir]
Donc il faut vraiment redresser
l'industrie française.
Comment on fait pour redresser
l'industrie française alors que le prix
d'énergie explose ? On a un peu de
chance par rapport à nos concurrents
européens parce que il nous reste les
réacteurs de papi mamie.
Réindustrialiser la France, ils ont tous
ce motl à la bouche
quand il y a pas des fondamentaux pour s
enfin quand on dit le prix de l'énergie
explose non le prix de l'énergie
n'augmente pas. Le prix de l'électricité
n'a aucune raison d'être plus élevé
aujourd'hui qu'il n'était il y a 3 ans,
4 ans ou 5 ans.
Je sors l'ancien PDG de EDF.
Non, [rires] aucune.
Ça a pas bougé.
Non,
mais 280 € le MW ça sort d' fantaise.
C'est Ouais, c'est
le coup de revient. Je parle du coût de
revient.
Coup de revient n'a aucune raison. La
France produit
modulo les accidents techniques
qui vont être réparés sur certaines
centrales nucléaires,
corrosion et cetera, mais qui sont un
événement ponctuel. On peut pas
extrapoler des événements ponctuels. Les
centrales nucléaires conjuté EDF
produisaient 430 TWh.
Euh, il y a aucune raison que le même
parc aujourd'hui en dehors du fait qu'on
a fer quand même fait son mais
entre-temps ne sont pas capables de
faire la même production
électronucléaire.
Pas de raison. Les barrages sont
toujours là.
Quand vous avez vu Macron
fermé Fenheim, très fier avec Ellisabeth
Born, très fier de nous annoncer ça.
Là, ils font marche arrière, il nous
annonce 12 ou 16 réacteurs en
construction sortie du chapeau. C'est
quoi ? C'est une veste. Ils sont pris
une veste. Ils ont été obligés de plier
face à la réalité économique et
industrielle française. Ils il ils sont
quoi ? Ils ont cul entre deux chaises.
Il il navigue à vue, il
la vie d'un grand patron français.
Je me suis battu pendant des années pour
refuser la fermeture de façonneil. Je
n'en ferai pas plus de commentaires que
ça. Bon, j'avais la conviction. D'abord,
on avait investi beaucoup d'argent dans
la rénovation de façon.
Je vais pas réussir à vous faire taper
sur un homme politique ce soir.
Pas mon objectif. Je l'ai fait,
[grognement]
j'ai pas tapé, j'ai dit mon désaccord.
Bon, il s'agit pas de taper sur
quelqu'un, il s'agit de donner d'avoir
un constat de désaccord. Je l'ai fait
quand j'étais en responsabilité
et je l'ai fait de manière très claire
et en direct sans intermédiaire. Euh
bon, [gémissement]
j'ai pris mes responsabilités.
Euh
après, vous pas obligé d'être d'accord
avec mes positions. Je dis simplement
que je les ai exprimé en temps voulu.
Encore une fois, il y a des traces qui
restent he de mes auditions au
parlement. Et vos auditions, vous avez
été absus par l'histoire. Je suis
remonté jusqu'à 10 ans de votre
audition. 8 10 ans.
Euh
bon, écoutez, à l'époque, il était de
bon de dire l'inverse. Donc, j'ai dit ce
que je pensais à l'époque, je le pense
toujours aujourd'hui. Ça n'est pas que
je manque d'imagination ou de
J'ai peut-être cette stupidité de pas
changer d'avis, mais mais forcé de
constater que bon, l'histoire ne m'a pas
donné forcément tort
d'act.
Euh
donc j'ai pas je ne vais pas me révolter
aujourd'hui contre
tel ou tel responsable politique. Je dis
au fond
qu'un outil industriel
ne se gère pas en fonction
des circonstances je dirais électorales
ou
et que la responsabilité ou en tout cas
l'honneur d'un patron d'une entreprise
de ce type de tenir
les positions claires euh
sans prise en compte de de ses intérêts
personnels. Je l'ai fait, vous le ferai
toute ma vie. Maintenant, euh
je veux pas revenir sur ces épisodes.
Vous connaissez moi.
On va parler un peu véolia et grande
boîte. Comment ça se passe la
prospective, l'intelligence économique
dans ce genre de boîte ? Il y a des il y
a des gens maison qui sont là où il y a
des des contractuels extérieurs, où vous
avez accès à des pipes d'information
certifié, propre. Comment ça se passe ?
Ce sont deux choses différentes.
L'intelligence économique, c'est une
espèce de défense du territoire. C'est
au fond, c'est différent. Euh la
prospective, c'est en principe euh
théoriquement enfin en tout cas une des
responsabilités de l'entreprise parce
que c'est elle qui connaît son métier,
c'est elle qui doit se projeter et c'est
elle de construire les évolutions à la
fois techniques, technologiques et en
même temps la compréhension du marché
qui est une compréhension très fine si
vous voulez. Bon et de promouvoir
d'ailleurs sa vision. Si je prends
l'exemple de Véolia qui est très
différent de celui de DF,
si je peux permettre une des
éléments clés de cette entreprise, c'est
le le la conception de la délégation de
services public ou de l'externalisation
de services industriel. Au fond, moi
entreprise je vous amène à savoir-faire
une mode de gestion qui va optimiser la
gestion de votre réseau, de vos outils
de vos infrastructures.
Je sais gérer un réseau d'eau mieux que
tout le monde. Je sais gérer un
traitement
technique, traitement des eaux de
retraitement des eaux usées. Je sais
faire fonctionner une une utilité
industrielle. Je sais optimiser le coût
de l'énergie dans un dans un dans un
outil industriel et je vais vendre ce
service sur des contrats à moyen ou long
terme à des
donneur d'ordre public, municipalité,
ensemble public ou à des entreprises
privées ou à des ensembles.
L'ingénierie contractuelle est un
élément aussi important que
l'outil
est ou presque aussi important que la
technologie.
Je dirais la technique, les évolution
techniques. Donc c'est un mélange entre
un schéma contractuel et une technologie
de pointe.
Il faut faire évoluer les deux. Il faut
moi quand j'ai rejoint la générale des
eaux en
au début des années 70 c'était un grand
une grosse PB française. On avait
absolument aucun contrat international.
On avait au 19e siècle la gestion des
eaux de Venise ou d'Istanbul tout ça
écien les avait perdu. On était
exclusivement français.
Il a fallu éduquer, transformer,
transmettre notre ingénierie
contractuelle pour qu'elle soit comprise
par d'autres pays. Aujourd'hui,
c'est une entreprise mondiale. On a plus
d'abonnés en Chine qu'en France. Donc,
il a fallu adapter et en même temps
faire accéder à la logique de la
délégation de services public des pays
qui n'étaient pas habitués.
Donc vous voyez, c'est il n'y a pas que
l'industrie ou que enfin que la
technologie ou que la
le le métier d'ingénieur, il y a aussi
de l'ingénierie contractuelle, savoir
faire une connaissance des clients, une
capacité d'anticiper leurs besoins. Euh
donc cette projection là, elle est
indispensable.
Euh politique, ils ont une projection ou
ils ont un court théramisme pathologique
et et ils gênent les gens comme vous qui
essayent de faire des plans à 30 ans.
Ça dépend. Euh j'ai signé des contrats
en Chine, des contrats de gestion
délégué de l'eau pour 85 ans
euh
à Shanghai
poudon euh à Tungdou, enfin dans
beaucoup de grandes villes chinoises.
Alors pourquoi ? Parce que alors pour
les Chinois
le temps n'est pas
il est plus long chez eux que chez Oui,
pour une deuxième raison, c'est que
quand vous parlez d'infrastructure
vitale, de services publics, évidemment
c'est des investissement lourds au
départ. Et donc évidemment, si vous
regardez le monde à 10 ans, le coût de
revient du produit, donc du service va
être important. Mais si vous projetez
sur 80 ans un tuyau
l'essentiel des inf, ça dure 80 ans. Du
coup, le coût de revient pour
l'utilisateur, pour l'abonné, pour le
client.
il devient accessible et si vous voulez
donner accès à des services vitaux à des
populations,
il faut raisonner à long terme. Et ça,
on a réussi à le faire comprendre
de même au Chinois en particulier, je
prenez l'exemple de la ch au français.
Ah ben les Français comme ils ont eu
l'avantage d'avoir eu la générale des
eaux déjà au 19e siècle même au 18e par
certains puisquelle a été créé en 1853
en 1853
et bien les Français eux ils bénéficient
d'un service existant ils ont des
réseaux ils existent les infrastructures
sont réalisées.
On a cru à habile de faire des lois qui
interdisent d'avoir des durées de
contrat supérieures à 12 ans par exemple
pour les contrats d'affirmage.
Alors ça renchéit les coûts bien entendu
mais euh c'est un autre sujet.
Lâchez-vous
le contrat long. Non mais le contrat
long est au fond une garantie de
sérieux. Alors, évidemment, ça engage la
collectivité sur une durée avec un
opérateur. Bon, et s'il déçoit, bah, il
faut à ce moment-là s'en séparer, ce qui
est assez naturel. Bon,
et peut-être payer des pénalités.
Lui faire payer des pénalités,
bien sûr, s'il a s'il est en défaut.
Pour ODF, le sujet est
au fond à la fois comparable et
différent mais il y ressemble.
Regardez le parc nucléaire, on en
parlait tout à l'heure. Regardez les
barrages.
Barrage, c'est pas éternel, mais ça
s'amortit économiquement,
industriellement sur un peu plus d'un
siècle.
Donc si aujourd'hui bon j'ai fait
rénover l'usine de Laarance, la fameuse
usine Marie Motrice, c'est vrai que ça a
été
un outil vous venez de cette presse
mythologique l'usine de l'arence ça a
coûté très cher. C'était pas rentable,
ça a coûté trop cher au départ. Mais
maintenant quand vous faites rénover
l'usine de la rance, elle est rentable
parce que les infrastructures existent.
Voyez ce que je veux dire ? Si vous vous
projetez sur une durée suffisamment
longue dans en matière d'infrastructure
de service public, alors vous arrivez à
à une vision beaucoup plus rationnel.
Bon donc
le réseau d'électricité c'est
ce qui coûte le plus cher dans les
services publics. Prenez l'eau, prenez
traitement des déchets, traitement des
eaux,
l'énergie.
Le plus lourd, c'est les réseaux
en terme d'investissement.
Une usine de traitement,
une centrale, c'est au fond moins
pondéreux que les réseaux.
Donc euh alors pour accéder au au
clients, pour accéder au famille,
bah évidemment vous pouvez avoir accès
au clients qu'à travers le réseau parce
qu'on a jamais transporté de l'eau ou de
l'électricité par voie hertienne. Donc
il faut bien le faire avec des réseaux.
Donc la question c'est au fond si on se
projette si vous voulez à long terme par
exemple à ce moment-là il faut tenir
compte de toute une série de paramètres.
Je citerai par exemple celui de la
démographie
qu'on oublie toujours.
La population mondiale aujourd'hui se
concentre le long des côtes
et sur les lacs.
L'Interland donc beaucoup de pays,
le centre des États des des pays est
vide. Est-ce qu'il est utile de créer
des réseaux
sur l'ensemble d'un territoire alors que
l'essentiel est vide et que la
concentrance fait ailleurs ? Donc demain
dans les pays émergents ou dans les pays
d'accès au services public, on ne fera
plus de réseaux nationaux, on fera des
réseaux locaux sur des zones à forte
densité de population.
Bon, il faut en tenir compte. Euh
ça veut dire au fond que des entreprises
dédiées EDF, Volia, Suè, bon ont
vocation à engager avec les donneurs
d'ordre, avec les interlocuteurs
des raisonnements à long terme quit à ne
pas aboutir tout de suite, mais à dire
au fond la vérité économique telle que
nous la voyons. à des gens dont la
responsabilité c'est justement
d'assurer le service public à leur
population.
Ça c'est c'est un vœux pieux.
Non non non. Aujourd'hui par exemple si
vous prenez l'Australie, vous allez pas
faire un réseau d'eau qui couvre
l'Australie. La population elle se
contente dans cinq villes.
Quand vous prenez cet exemple, les gens
comprennent.
Bon donc moi nous nous ne sommes pas là
en tant que professionnel pour faire
dépenser de l'argent inutile pour faire
des infrastructures qui ne servent à
rien.
Bon on me dis demain ça sera la guerre
de l'eau. Pas obligatoirement
aujourd'hui des puisque l'essentiel des
populations se concentre sur les côtes
faisant du dessement.
C'est accessible. On a réussi à baisser
le coût du dessement. Donc dans la
plupart des pays euh
civilisés, c'est ça ?
Non, même pas. Et même dans les pays
émergent,
ils sont civilisés aussi, hein.
Oui, oui, oui, bien sûr. Donc, je veux
dire, ayant des besoins
moins bien couverts que dans les pays
euh développés, bien sûr qu'il va
falloir aller vers ça. Donc, les
technologies s'adaptent.
Durant votre longue guerrière, est-ce
que ça vous est déjà arrivé d'être en
phase de politique ou de cabinet de
ministre ? et de vous dire en une
seconde "Mais en fait ces gens sont
juste cons, ils y comprennent rien."
Oui, [rires]
mais pas systématique.
Ah heureusement.
Oui,
ça
on ressort de là comment
déçu.
[grognement]
Oui, on nous on n'est pas de la même
génération. On voit le pays partir en
lambau,
l'hôpital,
le DF et bien d'autres. Et on se dit
"Mais il y a un problème, on est le pays
le plus fiscalisé pratiquement du monde.
Soit on a des décideurs, c'est les
derniers des crétins.
Soit le pognon est mal employé et qu'il
y a personne pour leur dire.
Qu'est-ce qui se passe ?" et passez-moi
l'expression
dans ce pays
parce qu'on est quand même français. On
sait trouver les coupables, on sait on
sait regarder où ça fonctionne pas.
Pourquoi on se refuse ?
On a tendance un peu trop, je dirais euh
naturel à chercher des coupables plutôt
qu'à chercher des solutions. Après
coupables,
laissons au peuple soin de choisir les
coupables.
Dans un pays démocratique, les
coupables, on peut les les sanctionner
par le vote. C'est bon, c'est pas très
compliqué. Bon, mais réfléchissons
plutôt aux solutions. Euh qu'est-ce
qu'il faut faire pour, comment faire,
comment aider ? Moi, je trouve que le
constat est fait par beaucoup de gens.
Donc, il faut les aider maintenant à
trouver des solutions.
C'est pas toujours simple, je reconnais.
Bila existe et au fond moi ma priorité
c'est plutôt de d'appeler à
au surceau et de faire des propositions
que je m'efforce de faire de temps en
temps quand j'ai
Il y a d'autres patrons qui viennent
vous voir en disant Henry il y a un
problème avec le pays il faut que tu
reviennes dans l'équipe parce que là ils
sont en train de faire d'envoyer la
France dans le mur. Non, je pense pas
non non,
il y a enfin vous avez par définition
toujours des gens qui vous font
confiance que vous avez connu, qui vous
sollicite et d'autres qui vous font
considèrent comme Mais euh
ce pays est un grand pays au fond. Euh
je crois quoi ?
Autrefois, quand j'allais voir
Jean-Claude de C puisque j'ai eu avec
lui une belle histoire,
je me garais, il faisait inscrire des
slogans sur les murs un peu partout et
juste au-dessus de ma place de parking,
voyez écrit
"Les pessimistes sont des spectateurs."
Ça m'est resté.
Voilà, je veux pas être un spectateur,
je veux être un acteur du monde qui
m'entoure. J'essaie d'y apporter une
contribution.
Une boîte française que vous regardez de
près en ce moment, c'est laquelle ? Mis
partf ?
Oh bah par définition, je je regarde
j'ai eu la enfin j'ai eu une longue vie
professionnelle qui m'a permis de
connaître beaucoup d'entreprises et de
j'en suis des évolutions. Oui.
Quand il y a des boîtes françaises comme
la TC qui va déménager au Mexique, quand
il y a des boîtes françaises
spécialisées dans technologie militaire
ou autres se faire acheter aux
États-Unis. Quand il y a des États qui
prennent des positions dans nos boîtes,
c'est on n'est pas en train de vendre la
France là.
Est-ce qu'il faut qu'on devienne
patriotique, protectionniste et qu'on
fasse la chasse à ceux qui veulent du
mal au pays directement ?
Oui, mais la chasse
et affirmé publiquement parlant.
Maintenant, la fête est finie.
Je pense pas que les gens cherchent à
faire du mal au pays. Ils cherchent
surah faire
il cherche à faire du profit là où ils
ont des cibles possibles. Bon
euh bon,
est-ce qu'il faut qu'on arrête d'être
une cible ?
Oui. Euh clairement oui.
Est-ce qu'il faut devienne un peu plus
agressif ?
Est-ce qu'il faut qu'on devienne plus
Je crois qu'il faut être plus lucide et
plus réactif. Agressif, je ne sais pas.
Mais non, pourquoi je vous dis ça ?
Je prends un exemple toute bête.
Moi, j'ai longtemps été très
réticent
à la cogestion à l'allemande. Vous savez
que chaque pays a aussi sa conception,
son organisation. au fond. On on a pas
assez de regard sur ce type de sujet.
Le monde s'est financiarisé. Nous avons
été envahis par une immense un tsunami
financier
qui s'est traduit par un court termisme,
par une spéculation
toute une dont les conséquences sont
tragiques pour le monde industriel que
nous défendons
et les conséquences que nous rappelions
tout à l'heure.
Certains pays ont mieux résisté que
d'autres.
Pourquoi ?
Laquelle ?
L'Allemagne ?
Parce qu'elle est restée industrielle.
Oui. Pourquoi ? parce que elle avait le
gaz russe pas cher.
Non, pas uniquement. Non.
Et bien figurez-vous que en en dirigeant
EDF, je me suis retrouvé dans une
entreprise nationale et que là j'avais
une loi alors il trouve que c'est le
hasard mais enfin qui prévoit queun
conseil d'administration est composé de
3/3 1/3 d'administrateur représentant
l'actionnaire état 1/3 d'administrateur
indépendant 1/3 d'administrateur
représentant les salariés
syndicat
et finalement Voyez, l'expérience n'a
pas été inutile. J'ai trouvé chez les
syndicalistes représentant les salariés
mes meilleurs administrateurs
parce que défendait l'entreprise
et puis surtout il connaissait
Oui, il la connaissait et puis c'était
leur entreprise. Il la défendre avec une
énergie avec une compétence
qui faisait que ils étaient très écoutés
au conseil.
Et finalement, je pense que si la France
avait une cogestion l'allemande, si on
décalquait
dans les grandes entreprises françaises
le même type de représentation au
conseil, on n'aurait jamais vu la
disparition des grands noms de de
l'entreprise France parce que ces
gens-là s'y seraient opposés.
Vous votez à gauche vous ? Non.
Non, pas que je sache,
mais ça m'a donné beaucoup de recul.
J'ai dit ça à un certain nombre de mes
interlocuteurs,
ça n'a pas été repris. Mais
voyez quand j'étais jeune, j'ai fait mon
service militaire dans la marine.
Vous êtes toujours bien vert.
Non non mais j'ai fait mon service
militaire dans la marine appeler
maritime et cetera. Je dis c'est quand
même très con. Pourquoi est-ce qu'on
apprend au marin à nager ?
C'est idiot. Un marin, il tient d'autant
plus à son bateau qui sait pas nager.
Je translate aujourd'hui avec mon
expérience
dans le domaine de l'entreprise.
Pourquoi est-ce qu'on met pas des gens
qui tiennent à l'entreprise
avec un droit de vote au conseil
d'administration pour bloquer des
décisions qui vont ruiner l'entreprise
ou la faire disparaître ?
Est-ce que vous pensez qu'une entreprise
va se déplacer au Mexique si dans son
conseil d'administration 10 ans 19 ?
Non, pas question.
Alors, c'est sûr, ça crée une inertie,
il faut les convaincre et cetera. Mais
après tout,
le fait de n'avoir au conseil que des
financiers que des gens sont font
travaillent pour l'actionnaire,
l'actionnaire si si on lui donne
une valeur supérieure à la valeur de
bourse, il est il est dans son devoir
d'accepter. C'est son devoir financier.
C'est comme ça qu'on a vu disparaître
les grandes entreprises françaises qui
ont été achetées.
Donc quelque part, je me dis
que ceux qui défendront le mieux la
France, c'est quand même les Français.
Ceux qui défendront le mieux
l'entreprise, c'est quand même les
salariés d'entreprise
et que au lieu de s'en méfier, on ferait
mieux de les intégrer dans nos
réflexions.
Après tout, certes, c'est exigeant pour
le patron parce qu'il faut bon
mais je crois que c'est une discipline à
laquelle il faut s'habituer à réfléchir.
Honnêtement, euh
le yaka faucon,
je n'y crois pas. Je crois qu'il faut
aller diagnostiquer
les vraies cohérences ou incohérence
d'un système.
Le système financier actuel à sa
cohérence. Il est meurtrier pour un pays
comme la France puisqu'on n pas
d'actionnaire.
Le système donc de de répartition que
qui est en débat aujourd'hui mais que
tout le monde accepte comme étant
essentiel
euh a fait que la France ne dispose pas
de fonds d'investissement et cetera, des
fonds de retraite comme des pays
anglo-saxons et que bah on a été pillé
par eux.
80 % du cas 40 appartient à des
actionnaires américains anglo-saxon 80
%. Le cas 40 a distribué c'est en 2022
80 milliards de dividendes
64 qui sont partis.
[grognement] Donc
mais c'est tout bête hein. C'est c'est
c'est la réalité. Donc je pense qu'il
faut qu'on réfléchisse qu'on s'habitue à
Est-ce que vous avez un message à faire
passer au salariés de DF qui voi leur
boîte se faire démonter salar de DF il
savent le respect que je leur porte.
Est-ce que vous vous vous vous les
appelez à résister ?
Non,
ils le font. Enfin, je veux dire, les
salir DF, ils s'expriment euh parce que
quand vous avez un cercle vertueux,
c'est-à-dire au fond quand les
représentants des salariés ont un un un
droit
de vote et une représentation effective
dans un conseil d'administration qui est
en principe
l'élément décisionnel dans une
entreprise,
et bien comme par hasard, les gens
votent aux élections
syndicales.
est beaucoup plus forte qu'ailleurs
et la compétence des gens, le talent des
gens est beaucoup plus fort qu'ailleurs
parce que la sélection naturelle fait
que
ils le savent.
J'avais des gens remarquable au conseil
de DF remarquable
en terme de compétences, de courage de
vision.
remarquable.
Donc oui, j'ai un message à leur
transmettre, c'est un message de
remerciement mais ils le savent. Donc
j'ai j'ai tire un élément positif que
j'essaie de transmettre. Encore une
fois,
un une des réflexions qui qui devraient
être menées si on veut faire évoluer les
choses.
Question internet. Pourquoi ne pas
sortir du marché européen de l'énergie
comme l'ont fait l'Espagne et le
Portugal ?
Je suis d'accord.
Moi, je n'ai rien à object.
Question internet comprend la volée.
A-t-il une position sur l'usage des
banques privées pour l'investissement
des grands travaux d'investissement pour
les infrastructures
électro-industrielles ?
Une objection ? Est-ce qu'on passe par
les banques privées ou on passe par
Bon, écoutez,
je paraphraserai mon ancien président
Guide Joanny. Trouve-moi des bons
projets, les financements ne poseront
pas de problème. Sur les infrastructures
du service public,
il y a aucun problème de financement euh
parce que tous les fonds
d'infrastructure vont se précipiter,
l'argent existe et cetera. Le problème
c'est d'en garder le contrôle et la
gestion des opérations. Voilà, c'est pas
le financement qui est le plus
important.
Question internet. Quelle est la raison
première du retard de la fabrication de
l'oper français alors que le PR chinois
a déjà connecté au réseau domestique ?
D'abord, le PR a pris beaucoup de
retard. Bon, même le chinois a été long
à mettre en place, mais euh Merv
Machenou a répondu cette question avec
beaucoup de talent. Euh [grognement] la
raison c'est que la France n'a plus
construit de de récteurs nucléaires
depuis plus de 20 ans et que une filière
nuclé une filière si elle n'a pas
d'expertise d'expérience et si on la
laisse en attente évidemment elle se
déprofessionnalise.
Que pensent-t-il des énergies
renouvelables ?
[grognement]
Alors le la meilleure et la plus la
meilleure et la plus efficace des g
renouvelables, c'est l'hydraulique
par définition.
La Chine s'est positionné sur l'or bleu.
Oui, mais c'est enfin quand on bénéficie
d'une géographie qui permet d'avoir et
de développer l'hydraulique,
il faut le faire.
Moi, j'ai incité mes interlocuteurs à
faire un effort supplémentaire dans le
domaine hydraulique. On a aujourd'hui à
peu près 12,5 % de consommation de la
des besoins énergétiques d'électricité
en France couvert par l'hydraulique. On
peut passer à 15 ou 16, il faut le
faire.
L'état des barrages en France, ils sont
dans quel étature ?
Ils sont en bon état. Ils sont en bon
état. Mais
tous les combien de temps ?
En permanence. En permanence. Bon, ça,
il y a aucun risque là-dessus, mais euh
mais on a d'autres gisements
potentiellement de de d'hydraulique
qu'il faut utiliser. Ce pays peut on
peut doper d'hydraulique d'à peu près
15 à 20 %. Il faut le faire. C'est une
absolue, je dirais, obligation.
Question internet. Et puis les autres
énergies renouvelables parce que je sais
que je réponds à côté de la question,
c'est l'éolien et le photovoltaïque
ne peut-être que marginal euh parce
qu'intermittent et et que le coût
effectif hors subvention n'est pas
compétitif et par conséquent
c'est une mine de subvention plus qu'une
solution énergétique.
Il y a des gens qui aiment bien éliminer
les subventions. même un métier pour
certains.
Oui. Oui. Mais ça l' dans le cas dans le
cas de figure.
Question internet. Comment voit-il
l'avenir industriel de l'Allemagne sans
énergie assuré ? Est-ce que la fenêtre
de tir pour la pour que la France
revienne sur le devant la scène ? Est-ce
qu'il y a une fenêtre de tir pour que la
France revienne sur le devant de la
scène ? Il y a une faise de tir pour que
la France arrête de perdre des parts de
marché euh revienne sur le devant de la
scène, ça va être compliqué parce que
ça fait ça fait très longtemps que que
l'industrie n'est plus
vous savez, on a même supprimé le
ministère de l'industrie pendant pendant
plus de 10 ans, hein. Donc il y en avait
plus, ça n'existait plus. Donc
bon
et puis au fond, pour être honnête,
aujourd'hui on a on est devant une
situation extrêmement difficile. Un
ingénieur euh
en en en en début de carrière, s'il
rentre dans la finance, il aura un
revenu deux à trois fois supérieur qui
de celui qu'il aura en rentrant dans
l'industrie.
Euh [gémissement]
c'est rapidement, je répète la question.
Comment voit-il l'avenir industriel de
l'Allemagne sans énergie assurée ?
L'Allemagne,
là on voit l'Allemagne répondu sur la
France. L'Allemagne, bon l'Allemagne ça
qui apparaît tous les marchés du diesel.
l'Allemagne va avoir un prix de
l'énergie qui va évidemment
l'handicaper.
Elle va réagir.
Je pense d'abord que
la situation de conflit en Europe ne va
pas s'éterniser. Je vois pas le conflit
s'éterniser et je pense que l'Allemagne
va avoir va être parmi les pays les plus
motivés pour faire en sorte que ce
conflit ne s'éternisse pas.
Ça pas l'air d'être le cas.
On verra, c'est mon sentiment. Euh, on
vous a reproché de pas avoir quitté une
place que vous aviez au conseil
d'administration internationale de
Rosatau.
C'est pas un conseil d'administration
d'ailleurs, c'est un conseil
consultatif, c'est pas un conseil
international, c'est un groupe de gens
qui réfléchissent sur l'avenir du
nucléaire civil et qui sont vous avez un
japonais, un italien, un finlandais, un
espagnol et moi plus russe qui
représente tr atomes. Bon, qu'est-ce que
vous voulez que je démissionne ? C'est
un conseil consultatif. On est euh
touchez pas de pogon.
Non. Donc euh donc les gens pas russe
non pas que
vous avez pas votre dater à Moscou.
Non non
vous n'êtes pas un agent russe.
Ah ça c'est ça reste à prouver mais que
on a les moyens de vous faire parler.
Vous êtes pas agent chinois ? Bah je là
aussi j'ai été soupçonné de ça. Non mais
je trouve que la caricature est toujours
malsine donc je répond essayie de vous
coller ça sur le dos. Oh
vous pouvez difficilement mec autre
chose. Qu'est-ce que vous voulez ?
Quand vous êtes patriote et honnête,
bon, on essaie de vous trouver. Voilà.
Mais ça n'a pas eu beaucoup de succès,
hein.
Alors, question internet. Euh
pourquoi ne pas utiliser les 1700
milliards d'euros des PEA des Français
pour financer une vraie souveraineté
industrielle française ? Bon, ça c'est
pas votre rayon.
Là, là, il pense à à apprendre l'argent
du livra pour faire le plan nucléaire.
C'est ça.
Ouis. Enfin, on dit n'importe quoi.
Enfin,
les pauvres français qui vont
amener leur argent sur les livréas, si
on leur dit qu'ils vont investir dans le
nucléaire, il y a tous ceux qui sont un
peu écolos qui vont fuir et les autres
qui vont se dire "Mais est-ce que c'est
rentable ?" Et mes 3 % vont disparaître
parce que le nucléaire c'est un
rendement très long.
Donc puis on va pas affecter une
ressource à un emploi. Ça n'a pas de
sens. N' pas ça n'a aucun sens.
Quand je vous écoute, en fait, j'ai
l'impression que la phrase qui va me
rester, c'est il y a pas de sens, il y a
pas de vision. On se retrouve en fait
avec des capitaines de pédal au Borgne
[grognement] dans le brouillard en train
d'appeler mamie parce qu'ils sont perdus
et et ils sont en train de crier "Au
secours, au secours, au secours". Mais
on fait semblant de piloter. On
continue, on continue.
Il y a pas de vision dans ce pays. Il y
a rien. Mais
il y a plus de vrais patriote.
Il y en a quelques-uns.
Bon,
je vous provoque, je fais exprès.
Oui. Oui. Euh,
vous allez chement provoquer quand même.
Ouais. Enfin, comment on fait pour vous
faire sortir de vos gs ?
Certains y arrivent, ne vous en faites
pas. Euh
un responsable, il est là pour un chef,
il est là pour cheffer, il est pas là
pour crier à l'aide. Donc pour moi, un
patron, c'est c'est pas celui qui dit
"Papa, maman, l'État doit me sauver et
non, c'est celui qui d'abord dirige sa
maison
qui
reste Vous savez,
j'ai beaucoup fait en matière
d'apprentissage quand j'étais patron de
Véolia. parce que c'était c'était pour
moi une manière de
de donner confiance et d'associer les
jeunes à la vie de l'entreprise et
cetera et j'ai beaucoup fait dans ce
domaine.
Il m'est arrivé plus d'une fois que des
gamins 16 ans 17 ans, 18 ans, des
jeunes, des apprentis me posent la
question "Mais comment on fait pour
arriver au sommet ?
Qu'est-ce que vous nous conseillez pour
pour devenir des patrons ? Et
et ça
finalement je leur disais écoutez plutôt
que de regarder au-dessus de vous, de
savoir si
votre patron vous apprécie, si vous lui
plaisez, plutôt que d'essayer de au fond
être tiré vers le haut, regardez plutôt
à côté de vous et posez-vous la question
de savoir si vous mettez le respect de
vos collaborateurs parce que ceux qui
vous portent sont beaucoup plus
puissants que ceux qui vous tirent vers
le haut.
Et et pour arriver en haut, rien n'est
mieux que d'être porté par
vos collaborateurs. C'est ça qui vous
permettra d'accéder au sommet. J'ai
presque envie de vous dire répondre la
même chose. Au fond, si vous arrivez en
haut, vous devez tout à ceux qui vous
portent et si vous vous souvenez de ça
toute votre vie, alors vous aurez une
vision différente. Vous allez pas
chercher papa, maman et cetera. D'abord,
l'entreprise sera pas en difficulté
parce que les gens seront soudés autour
de
d'une équipe et et et d'une ambition.
EDF n'est pas morte aujourd'hui. Euh et
c'est de DF qu'il faut attendre le
rebond. Euh ils étaient là cet hiver
hein.
Ils sont ils sont formidables et c'est
eux qui vont dire à l'État non ça on
veut pas ou ça il faut faire ça.
L'actionnaire c'est pas celui qui sait.
dictionnaire, c'est celui qui détient.
Donc au fond, moi mon enthousiasme, mon
optimisme, je le cherche à la base, pas
au sommet.
Je vais être obligé de vous lâcher parce
que vous avez un planning
hardcore. Deux dernières questions. Euh
la première qui n'est pas une question
qui est quels sont les trois bouquins
qui ont été les plus importants dans
votre vie ? Donnez-moi trois bouquins
qui qui sont nécessaires
pour partir sur radeau.
C'est une question pire. Je je ne enfin
j'ai lu beaucoup
j'ai beaucoup de bouquins d'histoire.
J'aimais beaucoup l'histoire.
Quelle période ? Quel pays ?
L'Europe essentiellement. La France en
particulier. l'histoire de néolithique
ou la renaissance. Non non non
l'histoire européenne, l'histoire des
Romains ou des Égyptiens à nos jours
parce que j'ai toujours trouvé
l'histoire et
tirer quelques réflexions et
puis j'aime si si je pouvais cataloguer
les les ouvrages dire au fond mais avec
beaucoup d'autres
l'histoire et
et je je dévore des des bouquins
policiers. parce que j'aime bien ça. Bon
ou d'espionnage. Euh
c'était lequel le dernier ?
Oh il y en a eu beaucoup.
C'était dans quel pays
avait des irondelles.
C'était aux États-Unis.
C'était pas [grognement] des irondelles
alors.
Non mais
c'était des dodos.
Mais mais encore une fois c'est très
varié. J'ai j'ai eu ma période
science-fiction. Je dévorais les
bouquins de science-fiction.
Quel quel auteur ? Quel
les vent vogimof et cetera. Enfin qui me
faisait rêver quand j'étais plus jeune.
Bradburry, vous avez testé un peu ?
Absolument.
Bien sûr. Mais voyez donc c'est par
période au fond des enthousiasmes. Bon
dernière question, ce qui n'est pas une
question, c'est laisser un conseil pour
les jeunes générations, une bouteille à
la mer, quelque chose d'impérissable sur
les réseaux.
Alors, je vous laisse réfléchir. Je vous
pose une dernière question parce que
laquelle tu veux qu'on pose ? Celle-ci.
Quelles seraient vos trois mesures
phares si vous étiez à la tête de l'État
?
H on verra ça plus tard. Euh
vous allez vous lancer en politique ?
Non non,
il y a trop de coups à prendre.
Non, c'est pas ça. C'est Non, pas du
tout. J'en ai pris beaucoup. Euh
non, les jeunes
l'audace,
j'aimais bien le
le slogan de chass qui était apprendre à
oser. une certaine forme de voilà
l'audace parce que
ce que je disais aussi au gamin c'est au
fond vous aurez des opportunités
vous en aurez toujours. Faites-vous
confiance et sachez saisir les
opportunités quand elles passent. N'ayez
pas d'amertume ou de regret. Euh ça
c'est important. Et puis le respect le
respect de l'autre. L'égoïsme fait trop
de ravage.
Moi
le slogan, je le veux bien.
Ça ça me plaît pas. Euh je préfère qu'on
dise vous le valz bien. Euh et au fond
si vous avez l'audace et le respect,
c'est déjà
passeport pour la vie assez important.
Oui, c'est puis la dignité quand même au
fond. avoir des valeurs, les respecter,
pas attendre le gendarme. On n'est pas
là pour tricher, on est là pour se ne
pas se décevoir soi-même. Euh et donc
c'est à la fois beaucoup de tolérance et
beaucoup d'exigences.
Mais en disant ça, j'ai peut-être l'air
d'un vieux con.
Je connais beaucoup de jeunes qui au
fond sont formidables. La créativité
c'est les jeunes bien sûr par
définition. Donc il faut qu'ils se
fassent confiance, il faut qu'ils aient
d'audace, il faut qu'ils avancent, qu'il
n'aiit pas peur dans la vie de prendre
des initiatives, de faire des choses,
même si euh c'est pas tout à fait
dans l'air du temps. Euh voilà euh
les mesures que je prendrai si j'étais
président de la République, écoutez,
il y a beaucoup à dire.
Je
je choisirai des gens de bon sens plus
que des gens des bacs + 28 ayant cursus
universitaire extraordinaire du bon sens
et du patriotisme. Avec ça, on peut
redresser le pays.
On va être obligé un jour de vous faire
revenir parce qu'on a pas parlé de
l'affaire al pas parlé de 25 trucs.
C'était trop court 1h22. Henry Progliot,
merci et bonne soirée.
Merci de votre accueil.
[musique]